The President of the United States is in some
hot water… with HBO.
In conjunction with Attorney General Bill
Barr's press conference discussing the release
of the redacted Mueller report, Donald Trump
took to Twitter with a Game of Thrones-inspired
image that quickly drew the ire of the cable
channel.
Its overlaid text, in a very Thrones-like
font, reads:
"No collusion.
No obstruction.
For the haters and the radical left Democrats,
Game Over."
Game of Thrones fever is at an all-time high
at the moment, with the first episode of the
venerable series' final season having just
aired.
As Deadline reports, HBO slyly referenced
this fact in a statement following the president's
tweet:
This is hardly the first time Trump's gotten
blowback for co-opting intellectual property
to make a political statement.
In fact, it's not even the first time he's
used Game of Thrones to do so.
Last November, he tweeted an image of himself
with the text,
"Sanctions are coming."
Again, the slogan was rendered in a terribly
familiar font.
And again, it prompted an epic response from
HBO's official Twitter account:
That unmistakably snarky comeback didn't keep
Trump from basically pulling the same shenanigans
in January of this year.
He posted another image that owed its aesthetic
to Game of Thrones, along with the caption:
"The wall is coming."
Following the November incident, HBO released
a statement saying they weren't aware of the
messaging but didn't approve of it.
Nevertheless, the network's spokesperson Jeff
Cusson implied that no legal action would
be taken.
At the end of the day, the case could be made
that Trump's tweets are parody, which is protected
under the Fair Use act.
Even, or perhaps especially, if the tweets
are coming from someone who occupies the highest
office in all the land.
Apparently, the president's legal team is
only vaguely aware of the subtleties involved
in copyright law.
After all, it's been barely a week since another
Trump tweet misappropriated intellectual property…
and that tweet wound up being removed.
On April 9, the president posted a video hyping
his 2020 re-election campaign.
It just so happened to be scored to "Why Do
We Fall?," a classical piece by Hans Zimmer
composed for the 2012 superhero flick The
Dark Knight Rises.
The video incorporated text rendered in a
font that was suspiciously similar to those
in the film's credits.
Warner Brothers, the studio behind the Dark
Knight trilogy, quickly responded with a curt
statement of their own:
Parody is one thing, but as any rapper will
tell you, you can't just jack other peoples'
tunes for your own purposes... unless you
want to end up in court.
While HBO may not have a case for trademark
infringement, some legal analysts believe
they could argue that the president's usage
of Game of Thrones imagery constituted trademark
dilution; an entirely separate concept.
Anyway, it's hard to imagine any Game of Thrones
fan thinking the image was proof-positive
of HBO and the show's cast and crew endorsing
the president's opinion of the Mueller report.
We're not in the business of taking political
stances here at Looper, but we are in the
business of taking a stance on Game of Thrones.
With that in mind, we'd like to point out
that the president's tweet doesn't make much
sense in the context of the series.
Unless we missed a crucial episode, we're
pretty sure there aren't any Democrats in
Westeros.
We suppose there are plenty of "haters" on
the show, though perhaps not in the way Trump
meant.
Regardless, there's no argument that the series
will be coming to a close at the end of May.
So indeed, the Game is nearly over.
Well, like the old adage says, two out of
three ain't bad.
Or is it?
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about Game of
Thrones are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.